in this lesson we're going to talk about
the very important concept that's
testifying s80 and that's called
rewriting equations or rewriting in
terms of you're solving for a specific
variable and it's a good skill to
understand and it's definitely something
that they want you to know when you take
the s80 so let's go through a couple
examples positive videos see if you can
do these on your own we'll go through
them together talk about ways to
approach these problems the first one it
says the area of a trapezoid is given by
the equation a equals one-half times H
times the quantity b1 plus b2 solve for
v2 okay and then the second equation
says that the volume of a sphere is
given by V equals four thirds pi r cubed
right are in terms of V so when you see
in terms of that means you want to get
the r by itself everything on the other
side of the equation just views and
constants like that so go ahead and
pause the video see if you can do these
problems and we'll come back and do them
together so the first thing I would do
for this one is if we're solving for B 2
is I would think about working from the
outside in towards that be too by doing
the opposite operation of the inverse
operation so here it looks like we're
dividing by Q see what happens like / q
so what i would do is i would multiply
both sides of the equation x 2 so that
gives us 2a equals h times the quantity
b1 plus b2 now we're still working from
the outside in towards B 2 i'm going to
do the opposite of multiplying by h i'm
going to divide both sides of the
equation by H so those cancel right so
now we're down to two a over H equals b1
plus b2 I'm going to do the opposite of
adding be 1 i'm going to subtract B 1
from both sides and I'll see I can
squeeze that right in there minus b1 so
what we're left with is B 2 equals to a
divided by H minus b1 so there you go
we've got B 2 by itself everything else
on their side of the equation we solve
for you to in terms of the other
variables okay so the second one we're
kind of solve for R in terms of you
right now we have V in terms of our so
we want to get this R by itself again
we're going to work from the outside in
towards our by doing
in verse for the opposite operation
right so instead of multiplying by four
thirds let's multiply by the reciprocal
three force okay sir with you so far so
that way these are going to cancel
numerator and denominator and then here
instead of multiplying by PI let's
divide both sides by PI or you can think
of it as multiplying by 1 over PI that's
the same thing as dividing by PI okay so
now what we're down to is we have 3 V
over 4 pi equals R cubed but we just
want our by itself so what's the
opposite of cubing that's to take the
cube root so this is going to be the
cube root and those are going to cancel
so our final answer is going to be R
equals the cube root of 3 V all over 4
pi and you've got an hour by itself in
terms of the other variables on the
other side of the equation and you've
got it so that's the idea it's an
important concept understand for the
SATs often times have you you know
rearranges equation solve for a given
variable and again I think the easiest
thing to do is think about working from
the outside in and just keep doing the
opposite operation make sure you do it
to both sides of the equation to keep it
balanced if you need to review this
lesson otherwise i'll see you in the
next lesson